hi I'm Dan McDonald along with Peter
Behrens and Ian Ford I am giving the
talk automated planar geometry will be
revealing some new features from the
synthetic geometry project or
Mathematica version 12.1 included in
those changes the will be a dynamic
version of geometric scene where points
can be manipulated
we'll also be introducing automated
geometric theorem proving functionality
and we'll also introduce an entity
property table with curated geometric
theorems from the past of the present
day
hello champagne we are the synthetic
geometry team at Wolfram I am Daniel
also speaking today will be Peter and
Ian and then also on the team are Lyn
Douglas Michael trot James multics our
intern gel fan and we are mostly based
here in Champaign right so kind of an
overview of the projects this is you
know we've been giving similar talks the
past couple years but we've got some
improvements for coming for 12 one so
anyways our functionality and crew
includes geometric scene which is used
for describing abstract coordinate free
scenes in two-dimensional geometry and
so for version 12.1 we are adding
capabilities for constructions and also
for interactivity so we once we'd have a
theme we should be able to manipulate
the points we've also expanded the scope
of statements we are allowing was this
not going down okay we also have so we
describe a scene we want to be able to
draw it so so that's our function random
instance which which will act on
geometric scene and once we've drawn a
scene we want to be able to make
conjectures up about the scene using the
the coordinate information we have from
from the picture provided by a random
instance so that's fine geometric
conjectures and then finally well not
finally apparently we want to be able to
prove theorems about the scene so that's
that's gonna be the function find
geometric proof this function was not
available in 12 Oh but should be
available in twelve one and these are
human readable synthetic proofs so
something that that a high schooler
should be able to understand and then
we've also what and the scrolling sound
working there we go it's just
highlighting and then we've also
introduced an entity energy property
table that contains curated scenes from
classical geometry a lot of Euclid but
some some more recent stuff
well recent in the as in the last few
centuries next okay so in our group we
always start with Bailey's theorem for
our example so right so we're just going
to dive into to some examples of how our
functionality works so Bailey's theorem
says let a b and c be distinct points on
a circle and line AC is a diameter then
the angle ABC is a right angle so using
geometric scene how would we describe
this we've got point a b and c and then
a center oh so we have a circle through
ABC centered at o we want to draw the
triangle ABC and we want o to me the
midpoint of a and c so notice we don't
mention the conclusion here but rather
we hope that it ends up looking that way
and it seems like it does
that's scrolling it's not working I go
there you there you I am a PPC person
yeah there we go I'm pressing too hard
just a whinny from my Sandman problem
here I guess right so we so we draw the
picture and we notice that now this
picture is interactive so say we've got
this point B and we for some reason
don't like it here we want it here we
can drag it we've got a little ghost of
it and it moves so notice that the the
picture kind of changed that's because
we didn't necessarily fix a o and C so
we don't want the picture like that to
change then we can make make some of the
other points anchors and now if I move
be around a and the rest of the picture
stays the same that's there we go
right so I also want to point out that
that there's no there doesn't have to be
a unique way for you to describe the
scene so this should describe you know
describe Daley's theorem as well say
we've got the circum whoops there we go
the circumcenter of of triangle ABC is
the midpoint of AC fully describes
Bailey's theorem and we we get a picture
so also point out that since this is a
random instance for running if we run it
again we'll get a different picture it's
right now more time I'm currently not
running it here we go right there we go
get a different
picture and again if we like we can drag
things around okay right so you know
this you know the formatting is as a
dynamic module with with a graphics
image but the the input form is still
geometric scene and it has you know all
the data about all our coordinates and
such which can be extracted later if
desired right so we have our scene drawn
we want to make conjectures about it so
we can run find geometric conjectures
and you see how that formats so so we've
got some highlighting so here our can
our conclusion is that line B a and line
B C are perpendicular and these are
highlighted there are a few equivalent
ones here planar angle ABC equals 90
degrees so these are both the
conclusions of of Baileys theorem right
oh one other thing I want to point out
is if you want to move multiple points
at once you can click pause updates and
that means that say I want to move a
around and I also want to move C around
at the same time without it trying to to
draw the picture and then it's like okay
this looks good now I want to unpause
and it moved them around
okay so right and then finally for
finding the conclusions we you know we
have it we can have it will default to
formatting as a geometric scene but if
we want to just extract the conclusions
directly we can use a sub value and here
we're also searching for a specific type
of conclusion and we get pointer angle
of ABC equals 90 degrees as
as say Lee's guarantee that would okay
so let's do a couple more examples so
here's pappases hexagon theorem so we've
got ABCDE F 2 sets of collinear points
and then it says that these intersection
points XY and Z should also be collinear
so anyways let's run random instance on
this and we draw a picture
good so again so let's say we we want to
move a point around so let's see we move
around maybe we want to fix C and a and
then move B around
okay so we've you know we we fix en a we
move V around everything else move so
maybe we want to zoom zoom out a bit so
we can see the picture better oops this
way and say we like this better than
than our original picture we can paste
this as a as a graphics if we'd like we
can also paste this as a geometric scene
it'll be down here right and then if we
decide that no we like the original
better because our functionality knows
best we can go back to the initial
settings and then finally just to
confirm our fine geometric conjectures
does in fact find that x y&z are
collinear
right so cuz neatest theorem has to do
with circles apparently so ABC is an
arbitrary triangle it was at
circumcenter and we've got circumcenter
z-- of the three triangles then it says
that the the straight lines between the
corners of our triangle and the circum
centers are all concurrent so they all
meet at this point k here in this
picture so notice that we have a random
seating option for random instance so
this is if you want to be able to repeat
your repeat your out output you can use
random seating and it's good for for
talks because sometimes the pictures
aren't good but I am a coward and I want
to make sure that this is a good picture
so holy cow it happened to work so right
so if I run this again with the random
seating I get the same picture and again
if I if I want to move move things a bit
around you know we noticed that a B and
C were our original Givens that were
arbitrary so maybe let's let's fix B and
C move a around a bit and notice this is
kind of a complicated setup but we can
still move things around and it
automatically updates very quickly and
so that doesn't require the the input to
be any sort of direct construction these
can all be implicit implicit constraints
but we will still be able to update
right and then if we run find you make
your conjectures on this we notice that
we do find that these infinite lines are
all concurrent so this will help cuz
need a sleep well at night and is
in his grave apparently probably there
if you got a geometry theorem named
after you you're probably dead yeah okay
so these were kind of classical theorems
for geometry you know we also deal with
more high school like problems so here
say we've got a scene with with four
tangent circles and the largest three of
the circles have these given radii and
we want to we want to find the radius of
the fourth circle so we can run random
instance two so to find the scene so
here we've got a B and C are big circles
and are the Centers of our big circles
and D is the center of our smaller
circle and if we zoom in we can see that
there's actually a circle around D and
then if we want to actually solve for
the radius of the the fourth circle we
noticed that we had named it rad so here
we have the radii of our the given radii
and then we're solving for this variable
rad and the circle centered at D and so
if we extract the quantity sub value
from this geometric scene it will be a
list of rules and we can replace rad
with whatever rad gets sent to which it
turned down is 21 so these large values
were not so random because we wanted to
to get an integer output apparently
right so finally one one other new thing
in twelve one four four random in since
the geometric scene is that we now
explicitly export
some explicitly support constructions so
let's go back to Euclid who I am pretty
sure actually is dead
so proposition want a book one of Euclid
states that given any two points a and B
one can construct an equilateral
triangle having a and B as two of its
vertices I hope you believe that in so
they if you don't believe that the
construction is to draw two circles
centered at a and B whose radii are
equal to the distance between them then
their point of intersection forms the
third vertex of equilateral triangles so
if we just wanted to draw the scene
without thinking of it as a construction
we could do it like this so circle
through of BC Centre today circle
through of AC centered at B and then
triangle ABC right so this gives us the
picture but this wasn't really the
construction that that Euclid had in
mind so if we wanted to do this step by
step we could do it like this so notice
that the argument structure here is the
second argument instead of just being a
vector of hypotheses it's now a matrix
it's a it's a list of lists of
construction steps so the first
construction step we say okay we have
two points a and B distance D apart the
second construction step is okay well
now we draw circles centered at each
point of radius D the third construction
step is we pick this point C that's in
both circles and then finally we draw
this triangle ABC all right and then we
have a similar picture but we have a
better idea of how we got there so that
was a simple example
Euclid does get a little a little more
advanced as you go on so Proposition 22
actually generalizes what we just did
sitting that for any positive
quantities are s and T such that neither
s nor T is larger than R and R is less
than s and T there is a triangle having
side lengths are s and T so this is it
should also be obvious but if it's not
we'll show you how it's done so for us
let's randomly choose a positive
quantities are s and T satisfying all
this so we'll pick s and T and then
we'll pick R and then our construction
goes like this so we've got a straight
line through the points D F G and H in
order so here we've got line D F G H so
inside of geometric seen lines are all
assumed to be straight so you know
outside of geometric seen these this
could be a jagged line but inside we're
assuming that there's an assumption that
this will be straight and then we've got
distances R s and T for how far these
points are apart then we want to draw
the circle centered at F going through D
so we've got circle through D comma K at
F because we are going to have K as one
of the points where these two circles
intersect so we've got circle through D
D and K Center to Def and circled
through K and H Center to G let's see
and then finally we will want to draw
the triangle F with vertices at F G and
K right because if K is one of the
points with these circles intersect and
F is distance R from K F is distance s
from G in Jesus distance D from K then
the points F G and K form the triangle
we want so free will run this from this
construction might take a while actually
run that
I can't tell this was running so this
again there we go we had kind of I guess
weird weird value weird random values
but we do get the get the picture so
let's do this again with some less
extreme values there that should be
better now it's run this again there we
go so we have our two circles in our
triangle and it satisfies Euclid's
conclusion ok so that is the new stuff
with random instance and geometric scene
and now Peters going to talk about his
his project which has been the automated
theorem prover so I feel really lucky to
be able to work on this projects been
really fun to work on and so let me
describe it for a second we're going to
be proving since we're gonna be creating
synthetic geometric proofs but maybe not
of a it's actually sort of a unique
function we wanted to have something
that could really be helpful for high
school students as well as hopefully be
interesting for professionals and others
so and something that could be
potentially used in Wolfram Alpha and
importantly for high school students to
output a proof that students can
understand and actually even the proof
that they expect to see so what we did
is we created something that I'm just
calling a naive prover rather than start
with some of the axiomatization z-- that
have been implemented before in systems
like Coke or there's something called
the area method which can contessa metic
geometry but they they don't really
produce that great that very that
human-readable
of a proof so what I've done here
is we have a proof system that actually
works internally the way that a high
school student or a Euclidean geometry
go about proving stuff so some of the
drawbacks are it doesn't handle
degeneracy easily we have to have sort
of special cases for that but that's
also true in the ninth grade classroom
sometimes that's sort of swept under the
rug and there's we it's it's still
evolving but it's it's not clear at any
point where what the the total theory of
the of this system is but the advantages
are we have a nice control over what
kinds of things we can prove and so
that's great because we wanted to be
able to prove this the high school stuff
first
we don't need to translate into readable
proofs because does that internally and
the proofs are very similar as I said so
the there's a precursor to this fine
geometric proof which is find equational
proof which came out in the previous
version so here's an example of find
equational proof can prove things in
well it will be able to prove things in
first order logic all any first-order
logic statement actually and some of the
props so you get out this proof object
and some of the properties that you can
query from it are a proof notebook which
in the case of find equational proof
looks like this so fairly readable and
also a proof graph which is really nice
to help you understand the flow of the
arguments which has some nice sort of
interactivity and then dynamic stuff so
let's get to a basic example this is a
really simple one-step high-school
problem where I just have some pair of a
pair of parallel lines and one angle so
I'll run that and let's do the random
instance and I have
it looked nice not too big so we're
given this angle and let's say we want
to find this other angle wzx so wzx of
this angle right here we want to show
that it's equal to 150 degrees so like
find equation we'll proof the first
argument of fine geometric proof is the
thing you want to prove and then the
second argument is the hypotheses and
then axioms or the geometric theorems
that we're familiar with our in the
background so if I run this I get a
proof object so let's look at some of
the all the properties that exist so far
not all of these are going to be in the
final version but I'm gonna show you
some of the possibilities so they have
all the ones that are included in find
equational proof as well as some others
so first we can show the proof data set
which is just an association which is
wrapped in data sets so it could easily
show the two axioms and the lemma and if
you you know move through the data set
you can get the explanation as well so
the the best way to see this is probably
the what we call the proof notebook or
what's called in ninth grade geometry a
two column proof where you have
statements and reasons so here we just
have one step really besides the Givens
and you have the explanation that
because they're parallel lines the
supplement the angle actually I forget
what this theorem is called but the the
angle on the other side of a transverse
of two parallel lines is is
supplementary we can get the result
itself in the Wolfram language in our
synthetic geometry language and we can
get a proof graph and note all these are
styling to be determined so some of
these things are maybe not the best
styling but we we have a this note up
here is given just to make it a nice
have one source in one sink so the
things that it points to are the two
Givens and then this is the conclusion
and I'll show some more this later but
if you hover over the the these are
probably too small to see that the zoom
doesn't affect this but it shows you the
the hypotheses and the conclusion if I
click on it it highlights that step so
this is really a hyper graph because
these two edges are sort of associated
with one each other one another okay so
let's do a little bit harder one so here
I have three lines that are tangent to
the outside of a circle and I've been
given some of the lengths so let's show
random instance of that okay so it
doesn't actually show the lengths here
unfortunately but we have so this one
right here we're given and some other
ones this the complete one right there
so now what I'm gonna do here is I'm
gonna use the the one argument form of
fine geometric proof which tries to find
all or as many as possible in the given
in a given time a little bit or number
of steps which are options all the sort
of the interesting proofs and you can
also you can also determine the number
of the depth of an expression that you'd
want to come out so you can you don't
want to have you know really complicated
expressions about a really simple
diagram so let's see what it what it
comes up with so it comes up with a
proof in sixteen steps and the notebook
is still a two column proof it still has
a a last element but this is no longer
the conclusion necessarily all these
steps in between some of them don't have
aren't necessary for other things some
of them are so it's a graph without a
single sink so it manages to prove all
the other distances and even find the
area using Heron's formula
okay so here's an even harder example
this is one that involves some
construction maybe not necessarily but
in you the usual way we'll find some
construction so we're asked to find the
area of the given shape you'll notice
there's a sort of implied - rectangle
there that would help us find the given
shape so let's enter the scene I guess I
don't need to do a random instance since
I have the image so this is something
new as well that we are still figuring
out exactly how it's going to work but
notice I have a pattern here because I
don't know what the area is yet and I've
described the area of a polygon in terms
of formal D formal b b c d so that's so
this is B C D and then D I should have
done the random instance maybe I'll do
that
hopefully this works oh I'm not sure
what went wrong here
anyway so let's let's run this proof
here see what happens or this one takes
a little longer actually maybe I
shouldn't have run it but you'll notice
I get the result out and notice that the
area is actually a different area it's
been cyclically / muted the vertices so
it's able to figure that out it's able
to figure out that if it finds an area
of a different an equivalent area of a
different polygon the same polygon
expressed differently it'll still find
it so there's the notebook it's quite
oops I should have just done this
so notice we do construct a point here
it's unfortunately main piece of ejx at
this point and that one interesting
thing about this is this point actually
contains within itself its own
definition so that's helpful for using
it in the next next step so we do
construct this point because we see two
pairs of parallel lines and we say oh we
should that's a parallelogram we should
define the fourth point probably that's
going to be useful and the whole
question of whether when to define new
points is is a really tricky one but if
we look at the the proof graph here you
see it it ends up finding the the 270
area and I can look at you know where
each of these steps comes from now
another interesting thing you can do is
you can actually trim a a geometric
proof to target a specific thing so if
we noticed in this proof that we're
constructing a point that makes a
parallelogram I wonder what the area of
that parallelogram is we can well let we
could first run the proof with just one
argument and then we get a big big old
proof graph that looks like this so
notice it doesn't have any end points it
just it basically ran out of time at the
one two three four fifth iteration
happens to be a coincidence after five
seconds and now what we can do is we can
and now this is a little hacky right now
because I said we haven't figured out
exactly how this is going to work but
I'm looking for a point which is not one
of the points that were given okay so it
actually has this wrapper right now
construct a geometric point but what we
got here is a trimmed or a pruned
version of the of the proof that this
parallelogram rectangle really is it has
area 300 so this is the trimmed proof
graph and I could also say that it has
some nice dynamic functionality here
where we can label the vertices
we showed you the tooltips we can have
indices to label that that match the
indices of the proof notebook or the two
column proof and we might have something
called augmented seen which could put
back the conclusions into a geometric
scene and even better to actually show
the construction steps as separate steps
of the geometric scene so that would be
nice
although if you think about that there's
some tricky issues there sometimes a
step is not really different in in
visually ok so now I'll do two more sort
of more advanced things that we can do
so one interesting thing we can do is
find the golden ratio so here's a scene
and and the the main thing to see in
this that the golden rectangle setup
here is that we have two similar
rectangles and that one side is is the
one side is shared okay and I'm actually
given this kind of helps the proof along
you can to give one length so the
actually it's going to find one over the
golden ratio so I'll show you this takes
30 seconds so I'll just show you a
notebook so it's the pruning maybe could
be a little bit better but in the end it
does so the problem with the pruning in
this case is that at some point we throw
it all into all these facts in to reduce
just did work better at some point but
so that's why it doesn't get pruned so
well because some of these facts are
actually irrelevant to be thrown in to
reduce we are working on a way to reduce
the inputs to reduce to define the the
minimal set of end points that that
proves this this fact so we can find the
golden ratio which is cool and oops that
was okay now I'm gonna proof Daley's
theorem although eventually Paley's
there might be a theorem that we include
in the sort of axioms of this system but
I left it out for now because it's cool
so let's we've seen the random instance
before and sometimes it helps to prove
her along to to name things or as I did
before to give them a a distance because
again the reason for that is we we don't
want to prove too many things about
things that the user didn't mention
right so it helps to mention things and
then the prover will prove more stuff
about it so if you can see we're looking
for the angle CBA or it could be ABC and
it finds the proof in well too many
steps in this case but again we have the
we have a way to shrink this but we do
have we do find out that the angle ABC
is equal to 90 degrees that's it okay so
yeah so notice we're using reduce here
okay and so my last example is sort of a
classic problem where you have a sort of
bicycle chain and you want to figure out
the distance between the two the two
gears and one of the steps here is to is
to find is to one of the steps in the
classic proof is to is to define this
point e which makes a rectangle and that
allows you to find various distances
like the one from C to K is the one you
want so it helps if we add that point E
and then we can ask for the distance
from C to K and then we get a proof of
that square root of 941 and you can look
at the proof graph of that if we want
and so we're still working on this but
against it should be out an experimental
version of 12.1 and really excited so
next we're going to talk about Ian's
going to talk about some curated scenes
can you hear me alright so I'm gonna
talk about some project that we've been
working on to curate lots and lots of
these geometric scenes it can be a
little tricky and it takes some care to
write these things it could help to have
lots of examples to look at also this
can serve as a useful reference so far
we've got about 260 approaching 300
famous geometric scenes these come from
Euclid's elements and mathworld and
other sources right and so these are all
going to be accessible through the
Wolfram knowledge base your main entry
point to that is going to be this
function entity value so if you want say
a count of how many entities we have you
would just use entity value the domain
is geometric scenes and you see we've
currently got 261 at the time that I
wrote these slides right now each scene
is going to be represented as what's
called an entity so here what entities
look like so using entity value you can
get a list of all the entities so you
can see lots of these kind of elementary
limousine
say high school geometry proofs we've
got more classical theorems like say
va's theorem Bret Schneider's formula
right and just a ton of Euclid we've
currently got I think all of the 2d
plane geometry for the most part from
Euclid's elements right and so this is
just another way of showing you can get
random entities you can also just use
the function random entity and explore
through them that way right now like I
said some of these entities came from
Euclid's elements some came from math
world and lots of other places so
another useful thing that we do in the
Wolfram knowledge base is to sort
entities and entity classes this is a
pre-release version
that I'm dealing with so these are just
a few of the entity classes that we've
got right now we'll be able to
categorize these more as we work on this
so we take the entity class representing
all of Euclid's elements and ask for the
entities that are in that within any
value we get that list now what do you
do with entities associated with any
entity are a list of properties about
that entity right this is any entity in
the Wolfram knowledge base each
different domain has different
properties of supports and so for the
geometric scene domain we've got lots of
things from you know bibliographic
information like where did we get this
information who proved this who is a
serum named after right
the real key thing here the main
property we want to look at is the scene
property which returns the geometric
scene object that Dan and Peter have
been showing we can work with so we saw
Theo Lee's theorem earlier we've got
Phaleas theorem right so if you take the
Lee's theorem and you ask for the scene
then this is one way of representing
Phaleas theorem as a geometric scene
that we've got curated and of course you
can do all the things you can do with a
geometric scene you can do with these
scenes from the geometric scene domain
you can find instances you can find
conjectures try find geometric proof
maybe we can prove some of those right
like Dan showed we have oftentimes
there's more than one way to represent a
given scene we try to just choose kind
of one of the cleaner ways but if
there's legitimately multiple different
like stylistically nice ways to
represent the scene sometimes we curate
these alternate scenes so for example
the angle angle angle theorem we've got
I guess one alternate scene aside from
the regular scene property which is kind
of a canonical one great along with
these we've got
natural language statements of what
these scenes are right in the case of
theorems this would be like a theorem
statement so does args theorem right you
can see that and there are alternate
statements so does args theorem is about
perspective geometry and there's lots of
different terminology you can use to
essentially say the same thing with does
args theorem right like I said we've
also got lots of bibliographical and
historical information on these things
so for example we can say who formulated
this theorem that might not always be
the same thing as who proved the theorem
right so in the case of the draws Farney
theorem
looks like Arnold draws far and he
formulated it in 1899 right but there is
this was a problem that he posed that
wasn't solved until later which was to
find the proof of that theorem and this
was proved by this person I won't try to
pronounce that apologies and of course
sometimes they're named after somebody
right and in this case it's named after
the person who posed the problem draws
Farney right these also interlink with
other pieces of the Wolfram knowledge
base right so there is a mathworld
article about the fins letterhead wigger
theorem about the draws for any theorem
about lots of these right and you can
access it access to those directly
through entity value as well using the
mathworld property this will give you a
list of the entities representing pages
on math world that you can go and look
at all right and also we can look at the
Wolfram demonstrations project a lot of
these also a lot of these famous
theorems are on there and you can get
related demonstrations and then using
those you know get the interactive
manipulates from the demonstrations
project and play with that
right so we're working on pushing this
out to everybody we've also got future
plans to expose this on WolframAlpha and
that is in the works so you'll be able
to just go to the Wolfram Alpha site and
ask about these things and we hope it's
useful and thank you for listening to
our talk
[Applause]